I am you look at me like you're sad for
me no that's me suppressing a huge laugh
because I love I love honesty yeah I'm
lonely I have uh anxiety man I am I'm
lonely and how many 3PO heads before you
start to calm down C3PO heads up I said
3PO
what do we see that's like usted we're
using two threepio you see three Pete
homes have you ever heard that three
Pete Holmes c3p homes there's your
episode name wow we did a C3 Pete homes
I want to get back to your loneliness
but your C3 Pete Holmes t-shirt and we
found out just how quickly the lucasfilm
people
we'll send you a horse head they don't
send a cease and desist they go full guy
oh God it's actually a Tonton head over
the tantan head in my bed with a cease
and desist stapled to its forehead I
don't know but they did send you a
letter I mean immediately two T-shirts
we did we don't really do many t-shirts
anymore but we used to do a lot of
t-shirts uh when I've been doing my
podcast for 10 years podcast you made it
weird I hate homes thank you Michael you
guys should listen to it it's really fun
very casual it is on the couch it's very
open we're on the same couch yeah
it has a sleepover Vibe some guests We
Touch feet is that true it really is who
have you touched feet with their choice
I couldn't tell you I think me and Maya
Rudolph might have snuggled up feet
really don't tell PTA she seemed very
comfortable
there's your clickbait Pete Holmes
hitting on Maya Rudolph I was enamored
with Maya what was I about to tell you
though so probably back to my loneliness
no
two two intellectual properties that you
don't want to [ __ ] with are you ready to
guess Star Wars Star Wars is one you'll
never guess the second one let's not
even waste time okay Prince really
because Michael Shea did my podcast and
he told a story sorry what was your name
again Ryan that's Ryan I just
I like honesty you do you know there's
it's inbounds five minutes after a
meeting you're allowed to say what was
it again
you got five likes you by the way you
get five
sex you're an [ __ ] five dead it's not
even good
more of an Essence impression I like it
I like are you do you always have us go
ahead finish your thought yeah
yeah thank you I'm mad at you I know but
he told a story about being at an SNL
party and Jack Nicholson was there and I
forget who the other person was there
but like big stores right right and then
Prince walked in and he was like and no
one gave a [ __ ] about the other stars
right and we were like wow they got
princed we kept laughing so we made a
t-shirt that said you got princed Jenny
fine the artist that I often work with
who's fantastic follower on the gram uh
she Drew this amazing drawing of Prince
and it said you got Prince and it had
like Jack Nicholson looking sad I think
we sold two before like a handwritten
scroll from Prince's estate I mean who
pays attention to that stuff who finds
it somebody somebody is out there going
like C3 Pete Holmes they're just looking
for season threes yes they're getting a
lot of C4
C3 right a lot of a lot of emails with
someone's job it's someone's job out
there I've flown out of a lot of gates
c3s are they just shutting down
Southwest cease and desist is this how
your your mind always works like this
doesn't it no I'm gonna be honest with
you Michael and [ __ ] oh no and Ryan